l'histoire que je vous racontais
bâtiment ou d'évoquer les souvenirs à
l'époque du train le très petit engin
emblématique est significatif pour la
preuve du français il y avait un
comportement qui m'a beaucoup touché qui
m'a beaucoup affecté sur certains
districts est un coin de l'île
il y avait des personnes qui me tend une
feuille d antiques cela une feuille de
bananier au bas de la rue et je pense
que c'était propre faculté premier jeune
à l'époque ils ne savent pas qu'ils ont
avec ce simple geste
ils ont fait une révolution ne sera pas
alors mon but est de mettre tout ça mais
de façon électronique de façon que tout
le monde peut y avoir accès le trek
tout le monde l'aimé tout le monde les
utiliser que ça soit à l'envi que ça
soit pas là l'église que ce sport peut
aller à l'école et aussi au lieu de
rester au bord de la route comme humeur
je veux jouer l'équipe les personnes une
était une feuille ou des antilles au
bonheur pour signaler le présente au
chauffeur du train auteurs alors ne
souffre des trains ne sont maîtres
transmettre avant la feuille et
klaxonner et la personne n'avait qu'à se
présenter en matière et
au lieu de l'acheter au bas de la rue
elle pouvait faire son jardin ou bien
stopper ou bien se préparer surtout avec
les mamans qui vont aux offices de
dimanche nous savons tous ce thème des
mains qu'elle aime être élégante et
allah et à l'arrivée des bustes c'est un
changement radical
je prends le bus depuis plusieurs années
et aujourd'hui encore je dois prendre
deux heures à la route pour être sûr
d'arriver à l'heure et non parlons pas
de ceux qui habitent très loin comment
vont apparaître avant que never à 83 5
heures du matin pour arriver à l'heure à
l'école est aussi non si si vous vous
prenez de 30 minutes plus tard que
d'habitude il ya de fortes chances que
vous arrivez en retard tu vois que votre
lieu de travail
si votre à l'école ou à l'église
et j'étais fasciné et je suis toujours
fasciné par le monde d'internet et des
nouvelles technologies j en idole il
s'appelle marc zuckerberg était le pdg
et fondateur de facebook
je pourrais vous séduire je n'étais pas
le premier de la classe ont battus tout
moment mais il y avait deux sont rouges
étaient très forts ce sont les
probabilités et les algorithmes l
exemple de probabilité il y à lui nuire
à l'intérêt et la fine gaule quatre
boules bleues une boule rouge
combien de changer contre une boule
bleue est-ce que vous avez quelques uns
de ces quelques uns je vous la donne
ces quatre chances sur un an à l'eau
lorsque japonais le buste à des
olympiques est là et la sortie des
classes était emmenée à la cades
je voyais des élèves y jouer à des jeux
vidéos avec les smartphones au bas de la
rue doit nourrir et sur les jeux vidéo
les ouvriers qu'il veut dans les jeux
vidéo vont couper les fruits je sais pas
si vous connaissez vous coupez les
fruits et je voyais à notre jeu d'un
côté qui est lui étaient sur facebook et
7 juin
joël qui ont été si facile d'accéder à
l'information
enfin le clip était très facile
d'accéder à l'information
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque ce n'était pas
tout le monde qui avait la 3g en tête et
en 2011 dépasse est apte au travail en
amont alors je je me suis dit que je
n'avais que la révolution est dommage
c'était un jour c'était la dernière
la dernière heure de cours je t'aime et
notre fils terre nous avait préparé un
examen qui se portait très probable dit
j'ai terminé avant tout le monde est mon
fiston vous demande de wilfrid était
celle de toi oui mr je suis sûr de moi
je suis probablement sur deux mois alors
la langue au président est d'accord
au moment de longuenesse de tam c'était
tellement content tellement eux
j'ai une très bonne
je ne pensais jamais autant ri aussi j'y
suis tous par mois alors j'étais c'était
notre compte on en a long à ton le but
c'était super
et cela que je voyais le buste et je me
disais et si j'appliquais mmm abbas ont
poussé le son de nabil est ce que je
pourrais prédire les bisons et c'est à
partir de ce jour je notais dans un
calepin le temps d'arriver l'aide de bus
le ton dès le début s'il faisait beau
être le souffre et changer si avec
toutes sortes de données avec la densité
du trafic avec les rdr partir énormément
donné avec tous ces données là je me
suis dit je vais essayer de prédire la
journée de demain
alors j'ai fait des probabilités en
faisons tutelle d'expérience j'ai pu
prédire le berceau c'est à dire sur on
va dire je pouvait prédire cette section
du disque qu'on libère sa livrée avec
deux minutes tout en remuant de retard
là c'est la probabilité
ils étaient quelque chose de super et je
voyais mon petit frère lorsque j'ai
montré où il ferait jouer à des jeux
vidéo que trois fonds c'était comme un
c'était comme un déclic
alors j'ai tout le temps conclut
pourquoi ne pas faire une application
tout cela pourquoi ne pas faire quelque
chose je serai peut-être utile pour tout
le monde
quelque chose si cela est démissionnaire
alors je conseille à programmer lorsque
je pourrais revenir je ne savais pas ce
que je faisais mais astier testeur ce
que j'avais imputant un but et c'est
toujours latent j'ai appris à programmer
en faisant des citadins au fur et à
mesure j'ai acquis de nouvelles
compétences parce que à l'époque j'étais
obsédé de créer le prochain fait beau
ils s'étaient abstenus alors je suis
passé mes journées
mais je voulais à programmer même si je
ne comprenais pas je ne passais pas
d'user et à petit chaque et le monde
donc et rouge et c'est là que j'ai pu
faire
cette application est l'un des meilleurs
jeux présents à pétré
voici comment une suppression bon là on
a un peu étiré d'image pour tous avant
mais est ce que vous voyez vous voulez
convertir la lumière c'est super alors
l'utilisateur de la géolocaliser et
aussi avec que les pièces préalable ou
installer des bus en réalité nous
pourrions nous donner une estimation de
temps en récupérant la vitesse du bes
commis au moins maquilleuse six minutes
best tours et aussi vous donner la
possibilité de trier de trier par le
type de buzz comme il ya des bâtiments
autour nous il ya des besoins populaires
vous aurez une panel de choix vous
devrez aussi des fonctionnalités comme
par exemple si vous habitez à la
montagne et que la de ceinture et
attention ça ne concerne que la de
ceinture pas encore les quartiers etc la
ceinture est tombé vous pourriez gérer
votre temps
c'est à dire que si tu te dis que nos
dix minutes tu dois être bâti minutes il
faut être bon et ont eu peur arriver là
il faudrait pour pouvoir avoir accès à
l'information
il faudrait une connexion internet 3g 4g
se montrent à la toiture
cette année leur est hostile à faire une
application entière modhac son publicité
interdite
mon manque de l'en but est de vous faire
optimiser votre thé pas d'ironie de
l'ast est au bord de la route
vous pourrez faire énormément de choses
imaginez si vous attendez deux heures
par jour
le buste la bulle bien non ça représente
une perte de temps considérable dans une
paire de tongs des lames donc à
représente aussi un temps gagné
vous pouvez faire plus de choses et les
honneurs et après aussi
mon but est de faire du possible de
changer cette image
cette image de désorganisation cette
image cette image que tout le monde la
connaît cette image je conduis un
tutoiement but d'amorcer toulon
changeait tout cette image vous faire
prendre le bus peut-être pour vous
voulez peut-être point du buste avec
cette application par tous et plus sûre
et plus économique
imaginez que vous faites que vous faites
le plein de votre doigt tu revois tous
7000 francs 9 une fois par semaine par
semaine
après ça dépend si vous faites dans des
parts dépassement oublier 200 francs le
buste en quatre sets à des quatre sont
faux barrage aller retour ce qui
représente 2000 francs à se mettre au
vert une économie de 5 me soit 7,9 en
mais c'est quand même beaucoup mon jeu
c'est parce que gagner des millions mais
faisons déjà beaucoup
donc si vous donnez le berceau ira
peut-être dans mois de voiture il ya
peut-être une fluidité de trafic
c'est donc loin de voitures moins de
pollution mais pour des gens de notre
fait nous re mois de pollution ya plus
pour l'entreprise
ça sera une nouvelle image tout a dit
qu' une règle de plus l'image de
transport classique a donné l'image
innovons innovant et moderne
c'est pour cela que on appelait au petit
2.0 parce que je me suis beaucoup
inspiré cette personne qui mettait la
feuille de route et aux bordelais et
n'avait pas constant qu'il avait fait
une révolution
la culture polynésienne et c'est là au
fil du temps je constate et je vais
répondre à des menaces est toujours en
développement mais hier on ne ferait on
travaille c'est fonctionnalités aussi
qui permettra aux personnes n'ayant pas
de connexion internet de trajet des
personnes qui ont des ministres
nous essayons de trouver un moyen pour
que ces personnes puissent accéder à
l'information
il sait quelque chose je travaille
depuis cinq ans et petit à petit c'est
quelque chose qui me passionne beaucoup
et dans le monde mon plus grand but est
de améliorer le quotidien
là pour l'instant de tahiti et peut-être
changer le monde